una alerta para rezar en un país
envuelto en una grave crisis de
inseguridad
el sábado la banda armada 400 magos o
una de las más peligrosas de haití
secuestró a 17 personas miembros de la
asociación de misioneros cristiana
administres con sede en ohio las
víctimas volvían de visitar un orfanato
en la periferia de la capital puerto
príncipe
estamos buscando la dirección de dios
para una resolución y las autoridades
están buscando formas de ayudar el grupo
de 16 ciudadanos estadounidenses y un
ciudadano canadiense incluye cinco
hombres siete mujeres y cinco niños tres
misioneros fueron retenidos por la banda
que lleva años sembrando el terror en
los suburbios de la capital y
secuestrando tanto haitianos como
extranjeros en las vías bajo su control
cerca de la frontera con república
dominicana
si bien las pandillas concedieron una
breve tregua en los secuestros poco
después del asesinato del presidente
joven el moho y la falta de seguridad
vuelve a ser patente y afecta también a
los locales y sus precarias de economías
donde fue aquí cuando escuchamos que hay
un secuestro el efecto del secuestro
sabemos que no va a ser bueno para los
conductores los motores y la gente no
sale a la calle no podemos encontrar
gente para transportar
guay según los analistas se han
contabilizado un alarmante aumento de
secuestros en haití que se han
convertido en una fuente de financiación
de los grupos criminales sólo en los
tres primeros meses del año hubo más de
seiscientos raptos